well I guess the lyrics to me are are
well I don't think they're more
important than the music but certainly
they are one half and you know the music
you want you want it to evoke things
certainly without words but then when
the words are there you want those words
to count every time I do you know you
just the the the task of songwriting
it's just to me it's there's nothing
quite as satisfying you want to get the
details right I like to think of it's
it's something of a painterly kind of
thing trying to create a picture but
tell a story at the same time I have
this it's not a routine so much but it's
something that I realize I've become
somewhat you know sort of have these
these methods or or rituals I guess you
could call them and I'm always
interested to read other writers
descriptions of how they go about what
they do whether it's songwriting or
prose writing or novel writing or
whatever and I think writers rituals are
fascinating and for me for me I have to
have my yellow legal pad and an eraser
and a pencil and and then when I finish
something it has to sit there on the
desk for a night if not more but
basically it's the overnight test and
then you get you know sort of return to
it the next day and you see if it's
keeper or not you know you don't really
know right at the moment that you
finished it you have to let it marinate
for a little while but in terms of the
importance of lyrics I mean that's
that's in the end going to carry you
it's going to say what you want to say
or hopefully it's going to say that
and occasionally not very often but
occasionally there is a mystery to to
writing I think to creativity and how
things come to you sometimes you think
you know and I think other times it's
it's just an extraordinary process that
you will never really know how you came
to that place to write this that or the
other thing and it's as if you know to
quote or paraphrase Bill Monroe the
great bluegrass Meister he you know he's
when someone said mr. Monroe you're so
prolific you've written so many songs
and he's just used to talk it was almost
like you could hear him fluttering like
his mandolin he'd sort of talk like this
and he'd say oh I just pulled them out
of the air you know and and that's
sometimes the best description I can
think of how a song comes to be you know
it's just kind of appears